as mass protests against the government
continue in the ukrainian capital kiev
meps have demanded an end to police
brutality and to the arrest and trial of
protesters pro-european protesters took
to the streets in their hundreds of
thousands when ukraine's pro-moscow
president viktor yanukovych postponed
signing an association agreement with
the eu three weeks ago
in kiev we have seen the biggest ever
pro-european demonstration in the
history of the european union a whole
population that wants to join the
european family mr hofstadt brought
together like-minded liberals from the
east and west of europe including from
the heart of the protest
i think we should
make our strong reaction towards
brutality or force is used against
peaceful demonstrators yanukovych made a
historical and political mistake closer
relations with russia is a way down for
ukraine
the trade and association agreement has
been under negotiation for years it was
to have been signed at a big summit in
vilnius but under heavy pressure from
moscow mr yanukovych said he was
postponing
president
obama
in the anderson
association agreement is a real transfer
ukraine proposal from from moscow is a
proposal to
go to the belarusian
way ukraine is dependent on fuel from
russia for its heavy consuming
industries and for the revenue it gets
from piping gas to europe the eu argues
kiev's long-term economic interests are
much better served by privileged access
to europe's markets coupled to reform